all right as bernie sanders now seizes
the front-runner's status in the
democratic primary he recently picked up
the endorsement
of new york city mayor i call him
comrade bill de blasio i'm not going to
say it
when he's not here and not saying he's
sitting right here anyway
he joins us live tonight to discuss the
sanders campaign uh the
de blasio's predecessor mayor mike
bloomberg and the state of the
democratic party
you know i will say this you spent a lot
of time with us the last time
um and people did say that at least he
had the guts to come on
good for you and i mean that let me
start with bloomberg
um i want to play for these comments i
know you're against stop and frisk yep
okay i would argue higher concentration
of crime
more police resources it's about people
but that's not how he defined it
let's play his own words
you can just take the description xerox
and pass it up all the cops
they are male minorities
that's true in new york it's true and
virtually every city
and that's where the real thing is
consequences is people say oh my god
you are arresting kids for marijuana
they're all minorities
yes that's true why because we put all
the cops in the minority neighborhood
yes that's true why we do it because
that's where all the time is
and the way you get the guns out of the
kid's hands is
thrown up against the wall and prison
you followed him mm-hmm mayor of new
york
is that racist to you oh sure sean look
this is thank you for playing that for
your millions of viewers because now
more people are going to see who mike
bloomberg really is
that policy divided police and community
i don't even think it's the policy
if there's a higher concentration of
crime in this part of town you put more
police resources
he's saying all crime only minorities
only arresting minorities but look
because that's where all the crime is
that's not true
he's totally out of touch with the
people of his own city when he says that
it's derogatory it's unfair it's not
truthful but on top of that
what happened it made it harder for
police and community to communicate and
be on the same page
it created tons of pain for parents
grandparents trying to bring up their
kids the right way look if you were
stopped
you're you're a law-abiding guy your
whole life you're a young person
you stopped your frisk over and over and
over again he said throw them up against
the wall
imagine what that does this song called
police brutality well look
it what it does is it takes away any
sense of self-esteem self-confidence
so here's what happened people came to
him clergy
elected officials people said please
this isn't working it's hurting us
he disdained them he didn't he just
michael goodwin said a 700
increase in stop and frisk in which is
the opposite of what he said last night
let me play this comment now
wait there's one quota so we ended that
policy and for six years in a row crime
has gone down
relationships between police and
community got better we added two
thousand officers on patreon
we need to protect our cops better i'd
get every one of those videos you need
to arrest every one of them
did you get them all we've gotten pretty
much all of them seriously but here's
the but listen to the punch line
he said bloomberg said oh if you don't
do stop and frisk you won't be safe
we got rid of it we got safer the nypd
has done an extraordinary job
and is now able to have that respectful
positive relationship with the community
let me play now everyone has a health
care plan
you know bloomberg has his own plan
basically a death pen oh you've outlived
your usefulness your
your you know your expected age you're
going to live to life expectancy
go home and die that's his policy listen
to this
at the rate we're going healthcare is
going to bankrupt us so
not only do we have a problem it's going
back to us and we've got to sit here and
say which things we're going to do and
which things we're not
nobody wants to do that you know you
show up
with prostate cancer and you're 95 years
old
we should say go and enjoy have an ice
cream leave a long life
there's no cure and you can't do
anything if you're a young person we
should do something about it
society's not willing to do that yet
go home and die sean that's what we call
bedside manner right there oh geez
uh no but look at this this and you saw
it in the two debates this guy has
no common touch no connection to people
look one of the things you and i have
talked about you've got millions of
viewers who are working americans
everyday people
and i'm here with you because i want to
talk to them too we should all be
talking to each other
but when you watch michael bloomberg on
that debate stage he's got no clue what
everyday people are going through he
doesn't care to know
when he was mayor here if you tried to
talk about what's happening in the
neighborhood what was happening to
everyday people
all he could think about was that elite
he comes from
and it comes through here how do you
talk about health care we've got lots of
people tens of millions of people who
need health care
how do we work together to get it to
them the right way not
how do we plan your funeral uh that was
shocking to me but
what's interesting about this and the
reason i'm asking you first about him is
you're not supporting him i will say
this about sanders
and i'm over the years you need to tell
him to come back on the show he's
ducking me but at least he
he believes this crap i mean he really
he's the he is sincere
this guy supported stop and frisk for 12
years
seven years when you were mayor and then
says oh i'm running for president uh oh
african americans may not like this and
it starts with the crocodile tears you
agree that's phony 100
if he were not running for president
right now we still wouldn't have that
apology but what you said about bernie
sanders is right
and working people get this about bernie
it's very important you could disagree
with him but you don't
doubt that what he is saying is the
truth you know a lot of politicians sean
i do
and most politicians bluntly you have to
wonder if you're getting the real thing
from them what about the
praise of venezuela what about his
praise of venezuela cuba honeymoons in
those former soviet union
they killed millions in the former
soviet union
cold war oh no no cold war that's when
he was there
come on he was there you know when he
was there a nation actually makes a
great point
the week he was there you know who else
was there ronald reagan yeah but he was
actually telling them
to you know among other things that they
better change it was
trust but verified years ago he's
through strength and
what actually everyday americans are
looking for they don't want to talk
about the cold war they want to talk
about how we're going to
get people health insurance how are we
going to get make sure that people have
a decent job and decent wages how are we
going to make sure the middle class
survives
and how we're going to deal with climate
change all things where america
you want to get rid of bernie wants to
get rid of oil and gas
how do we survive it's the lifeblood of
the world's economy we talked about this
before but let me just make the point
bernie sanders believes in what he's
talking about he gives you an incredibly
clear picture of where he wants to go
by the way that is what great leaders do
i think you have a feeling for ronald
reagan ronald reagan you actually knew
where he wanted to go
you know it would bernie sanders he is
about working people the elites
aren't about working people he is here's
the problem
he's going to tax people by his own
admission that make 29 000 or more
they're going to get slapped with a 4
tax increase to pay for medicare for all
he's going to high-income earners
they're going to see a
top federal rate of 52 percent a hike of
15 percent
capital gains he's going to raise he
wants a wealth tax the death tax
77 percent okay new york gets another
what 10
i think your city gets 3 percent the
federal government that means
you tax people they pay their taxes then
you take another bite at the apple with
the wealth tax if you were dumb enough
to save money
and then when you die you got to give 90
percent of your wealth
don't you think that's legalizing
stealing no you don't know but you
should have all that money
we should just hand it over to you yeah
you know all you may unite
republicans democrats independents two
things
one too much money in politics
they'd all like to see the big money out
of politics two they all think
the wealthy are not paying their fair
share in taxes no one doubts that bernie
sanders is going to work to make it a
more
fair you got to give me a straight
answer how much of
every dollar after you pay state local
federal sales property taxes
should everybody be allowed to keep
anybody looking we don't know no in the
box
i'm not going to do a single number the
bottom line is why not the bottom line
is
folks who for decades very wealthy
people not answering
how much should people be people they're
earning it
how did they get that got that way in
large measure because of government
policies that help them
it's time for people to pay how much
most republicans think the wealthy are
not paying their fair share in taxes and
this is
you want to legalize stealing no and you
want to confiscate it
and then you want to give it away so you
build your power i got a prediction for
you what
a lot of your viewers have a choice
between biden
bloomberg bernie sanders a lot of your
viewers who are democrats a lot of your
viewers are labor union members
they're going with bernie sanders and
trump's going to win bernie sanders is
going to win
we agree bernie sanders is going to win
we're here to now project donald j
trump reelected the 45th president of
the united states we'll invite you to
bernie's inauguration oh i can hardly oh
okay great i'm sure he wants to be there
he won't even come off tell him to come
on my show
you're going to tell him of course all
right thank you thank you for coming in